merci à toi surtout chez éric merci de
me faire l'amitié de retrouver ma
famille politique c'était toujours un
bonheur pour moi d'autant que dans le
monde intellectuel j'ai beaucoup de
défauts 1 je suis pas anti libérale 2 je
ne suis pas souverainiste je suis pro
européen je ne suis pas pessimiste et je
ne passe pas mon temps à pleurer donc
c'est vraiment gentil de m'inviter quand
même c'est une grande chance normalement
c'est une conférence qui dure deux
heures je vous la fait en un quart
d'heure
mais enfin ça m'oblige à faire tenir la
donne dans le marron quand même c'est un
peu spécial
trois âges du travail je vais vous
raconter l'histoire intellectuelle du
droit du travail elle est absolument
passionnante
un jour j'en ferai un livre c'est
vraiment une histoire à proprement
parler génial il ya trois grandes âge du
travail sur le plan moral et
intellectuel le premier âge il ya un
effet larsen là je t'aime éloigné un peu
le premier âge c'est l'âge
aristocratique ça commence avec les
grande vision morale du monde de platon
et d'aristote ça va durer jusqu'à la
révolution française
je vais le dire de manière très simple
pendant des siècles et des siècles
l'aristocrate se définit d'abord et
avant tout comme celui qui ne travaille
pas pourquoi ils travaillent pas parce
que dans le monde aristocratique vous
trouvez ça déjà dans la république de
platon
il existe une hiérarchie naturelle des
êtres il ya des bons par nature c'est
les aristos y c'est les meilleurs il
faut leur confier le pouvoir il ya des
moyens par nature et puis il ya des
médiocres par nature sont les esclaves
dans le monde aristocratique dans le
monde grec comme dans la société féodale
européenne et donc dans la mesure où il
ya une hiérarchie naturelle j'insiste
surnaturel des êtres et bien
l'aristocrate celui qui est bon par
nature ne travaille pas qu'est ce qu'il
fait
ne confondez pas les deux on les confond
tout le temps il s'exerce mais ils ne
travaillent pas qu'est ce que c'est que
l'exercice par opposition au travail
l'exercice est ce qui consiste chez un
être très doué un mc enroe tennis un
mine mais nuit nos violons à actualiser
des dispositions naturelles qui sont
virtuellement présente à la naissance
mais qu'il faut
actualisé rendre réel par l'exercice
l'homme doué la femme douée s'exerce
mais ne travaille pas le travail et le
contraire de l'exercice dans le monde
aristocratique travailler c'est lutter
contre une nature rétive pour essayer de
la modifier de l'améliorer de la
transformer de la civilisé s'exercer
s'est actualisée une nature bien doué je
ne développe pas ça mais vous voyez que
sur le plan éducatif pédagogique dans le
cadre de l'école ça donne lieu à deux
visions totalement opposées de
l'éducation l'éducation aristocratique
consiste à s'exercer à exercer les
lèvres a actualisé ces dispositions
naturelles l'éducation méritocratique
républicaine elle consistera au
contraire à transformer nature rétive
deuxième âge du travail ça commence avec
la parabole des talents dans l'évangile
de matthieu un tout petit peu dans
l'évangile de luc mais c'est surtout
dans matthieu la parabole des talents
est souvent mal comprise elle est
absolument génial elle est à l'origine
de toute l'idéologie méritocratique
républicaine paradoxalement très grande
continuité entre la république et le
christianisme
que dit la parabole des talents je la
rappelle très brièvement pour ceux qui
auraient oublié leurs bases
eh bien ça arrive c'est l'histoire d'un
maître d'un seigneur qui part pour un
long voyage il convoque ses trois
serviteurs et il donne cinq talents au
premier les talents les talenta en grec
ce sont des pièces d'argent qui ont une
très grande valeur et donc on comprend
symboliquement que ça signifie que le
premier serviteur est le plus doué celui
qui a le plus de talent le deuxième
serviteur est convoqué on lui donne deux
talents de talenta de pièces d'argent et
le troisième on lui en donne une seule
et puis le maître parfaire son voyage et
il revient au bout de quelques mois il
convoque à nouveau ces trois serviteurs
et il leur demande de faire le bilan le
premier serviteur qui a eu cinq talenta
cinq pièces d'argent en rang 10 c'est
comme dans les trois petits cochons
c'est comme dans les contes de fées
littérairement ce très important la même
formule va revenir
elle a la même signification lemaitre
lui dis bon serviteur entre dans la joie
de ton maître
et puis le deuxième serviteur il a eu
deux iran quatre mêmes proportions
mêmes phrases bon serviteur entre dans
la joie de ton maître et puis le
troisième serviteur il a eu peur on lui
a donné un talent il l'a enterrée
il a eu peur il a manqué de confiance
l'étymologie est très important scum
fides il a manqué deux fois et l'a
enterré le talent il le rend intacte au
maître en lui disant m je sais que tu es
un seigneur dur et que tu peux me punir
mais tu vois j'ai eu peur j'ai enterré
la pièce je claro intacte et évidemment
le maître est fou de rage le shass le
vouent aux gémonies et le shass de son
palais en fait ils l'envoient
probablement à la mort que signifie la
parabole des talents par rapport au
monde aristocratique c'est la fin du
monde aristocratique que signifie la
parabole des talents et l'héritage
républicain en sera directement tiré la
parabole des talents signifie que la
dignité morale d'un être humain ne
dépend pas de sa nature de ce qu'il a
reçu en partage au départ on dirait
aujourd'hui de sa génétique mais de ce
qu'il en fait autrement dit du travail
et c'est avec la parabole des talents
qu'on va commencer dans la vieille
europe à valoriser le travail a parlé de
valeurs du travail donc un être qui ne
travaillent pas n'est pas simplement un
homme qui ne travaillent pas n'est pas
simplement un homme pauvre parce qu'il
n'a pas de revue
c'est un pauvre homme parce qu'il ne si
lille ne se civilise pas un homme pauvre
et un pauvre homme c'est pas la même
chose en français on comprend et donc
l'idée est la suivante c'est que les
qualités naturelles écoutez bien ça les
qualités naturelles et vous trouverez ça
au début de la plus grande morale
républicaine qui soit la morale de kent
j'ai traduit la critique de la raison
pratique dans la pléiade et ça commence
comme ça les qualités naturelles n'ont
aucune valeur morale dit kent dans la
suite de la parabole des talents on s'en
fiche
l'intelligence la beauté et la preuve
que ses qualités la mémoire tous que la
force
tout ce que vous voudrez les qualités
naturelles n'ont aucune valeur morale la
preuve c'est qu'elles peuvent être mises
indifféremment au service du mal comme
au service du bien et donc ce qui compte
moralement c'est ce qu'on va faire de ce
qu'on a reçu comme héritage génétique
c'est pas l'héritage lui même et donc le
travail ça va nous valoir dans
l'histoire l'europe c'est pas très connu
mais ce que je vais vous dire est
historiquement vrai est assez
significatifs s'est amusé en même temps
les moines dans les monastères vont être
obligés de travailler
ce sont au moyen âge les seuls dans les
couches les traits ceux qui lisent le
latin et le grec qui vont être obligées
de travailler de leurs mains ça nous
faudra des inventions magnifique le
champagne par don pérignon et beaucoup
d'autres inventions il faut consommer
avec modération mais qui porte le nom de
cet héritage monastique monacale le
cointreau la chartreuse la bénédictine
et oui c'est dingue ça vient vous allez
dans les monastères du sud de la france
par exemple la chartreuse de la verne
qui est magnifique
vous voyez toujours des pressoirs à
huile d'olive donc vous voyez à chaque
fois des instruments qui signifiait que
en accord avec la parabole des talents
on valoriser le travail et il fallait y
compris pour les moines qui lisait le
grec et latin travail et l'école
républicaine sortira directement de
cette parabole des talents don camillo
et peppone sont les mêmes en vérité et
donc le fameux peut mieux faire
on a tous connu il peut mieux faire on
avait offert en 68 un tampon avec peut
mieux faire à nos professeurs pour
qu'ils puissent remplir le bulletin
scolaire plus rapidement le canonique
peut mieux faire avec les bonnets d'âne
et les bons points ça va ensemble
il signifiait la chose suivante c'est
que comme mathieu dans l'évangile le
hussard de la république même si bouffe
du curé le matin au petit déjeuner il
n'empêche il est dans la même lignée
ils considèrent qu'ils préfèrent suceurs
de la république éventuellement
anticlérical il préfère un élève peu
doué qui est pas un aristocrate mais qui
travaillent et qui est méritant un élève
qui commandent y a des facilités mais
qui ne font rien ça c'est la bête noire
du sart de la république et donc c'est
la même idée que celle de la parabole
des talents là l'école républicaine ne
sera rien d'autre et d'ailleurs ça vaut
à peu près pour tous les rapports du
christianisme et de la république en
vérité l'école républicaine même
anticlérical ne sera rien d'autre en
vérité pour l'essentiel qu'une
sécularisation de
la tradition chrétienne la méritocratie
républicaine sortira directement de la
parabole des talents troisième âge et
c'est avec lui que je m'arrêterai c'est
pas pour faire un discours facile contre
68 c'est pas le sujet mais dans les
années 60 on voit apparaître les
idéologies de la fin du travail pourquoi
on voit apparaître les idéologies de la
fin du travail le travail redevient
l'ennemi ce sera d'ailleurs à l'origine
de nos fameuses 35 heures pourquoi le
travail devient l'ennemi parce qu'on
voit apparaître un nouveau paradigme
morale nouvelle vision morale du monde
dans les années 60 ce que j'ai appelé
l'éthique de l'authenticité
quelle est l'idée l'idée c'est que dans
l'éthique chrétienne républicaine que je
viens d'évoquer cette éthique du travail
du mérite de l'effort dans cette éthique
méritocratique à la foi chrétienne et
républicaine l'idée moral par excellence
c'est l'idée suivante c'est l'idée que
chaque individu chacun d'entre nous doit
s'efforcer doit travailler doit
s'efforcer d'atteindre des normes qui
sont transcendante qui sont supérieures
extérieur à lui ne pas voler ne pas
mentir tout ça est très difficile
surtout en politique on le sait est donc
bien le dire bon mais on le sait très
bien et donc il faut atteindre des
normes et puis ces normes elles vont
être dans le cadre de l'école inscrits
de manière sacré dans les programmes
scolaires et chacun sait trés donc aucun
d'entre nous ne connaît par coeur même
les programmes de troisième je parle
ceux d'avant ceux d'aujourd'hui on peut
y arriver mais ceux d'avant bon c'était
difficile encore et donc on sait très
bien qu'il ya d'énormes idéal des
standards supérieur extérieure à nous
transcendant par rapport à l'individu et
que le mérite c'était pour chaque
individu de s'efforcer d'atteindre ces
normes transcendante idéal supérieur à
nous ce qu'on voit apparaître dans les
années 60 c'est autre chose c'est
l'éthique de l'authenticité
le mot clé de mai 68 c'est la lutte
contre l'aliénation que disait l'école
chrétienne républicaine elle disait
devient autre que ce que tu es au départ
il s'agissait de prendre un enfant au
départ un culte ne sachant ni lire ni
écrire
et puis de le rendre à l'arrivée
autre que ce qu'il était au départ donc
aliénation au sens latin du terme non
avec les années 60 on voit apparaître ce
que j'appelle les tics de l'authenticité
qui va être une éthique de la fin du
travail c'est à dire une éthique de
l'épanouissement de soi non pas devient
autres mais bio self deviens ce que tu
es
est ce que vous êtes jamais demandé
pourquoi dans toutes les grandes villes
occidentales
le dimanche les individus se met à
courir comme des fous dans les jardins
publics autour des lacs et ils appellent
ça le jogging il s'agit d'être bien dans
sa tête bien dans sa peau explosion des
psychothérapies entre où tous genres y
compris dans l'entreprise l'analyse
transactionnelle la bioénergie le
rolfing les les psychothérapies encore
une fois en tous genres bien dans sa
tête mais aussi bien dans sa peau le
boom des de la diététique des deux du
bodybuilding et des centres de fitness
de tout ce qui va avec est donc bien
dans sa tête bien dans sa peau non
surtout ne devient pas autre que ce que
tu aimes et deviens ce que tu es be
yourself
frohmuhl à la fois de nietzsche et de
freud deviens ce que tu es encore une
fois et non pas et lève toi pourquoi on
appelait l'élève un élève parce qu'il
s'agissait de l'élu et là on n'est plus
avec des élèves on est avec des enfants
et avec des enfants dont la finalité de
l'école aujourd'hui très largement et de
faire en sorte qu'ils deviennent eux
mêmes et non pas qu'il devienne autre
que ce qu'ils étaient au départ on est
passé de l'instruction publique à
l'éducation nationale les mots ont un
sens je développe pas ça mais ça
mériterait un long développement et donc
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au tour du
travail c'est qu'on a un très grand
débat dans la société extrêmement
violent d'une certaine manière et c'est
assez largement un débat droite gauche
mais pas uniquement parce qu'il ya des
républicains
jean pierre chevènement ou d'autres à
gauche comme il ya des libéraux
démocrates à droite
donc c'est pas simplement débat droite
gauche n'est assez largement quand même
entre disons la deuxième gauche et puis
des républicains de droite comme de
gauche
il ya d'un côté ceux qui sont pour la
fin du travail et qui considèrent que le
c'est l'ennemi c'est les 35 heures qui
était qui ont été l'aboutissement de
cette idéologie et que l'idéal serait de
ne pas travailler
et puis vous avez au contraire toute
l'éthique chrétienne républicaine qui
continue d'exister qui se bat contre
cette première idéologie acquis dit mais
non encore une fois un homme qui ne
travaille pas c'est pas simplement un
homme pauvre parce qu'il n'a pas de
revenus mais c'est un pauvre homme parce
qu'ils ne reculent se cultive pas et ne
se civilise pas et le travail a une
valeur en soi
et moi j'ai compris ça il ya très
longtemps j'ai adoré la phrase de
baudelaire qui disait finalement disait
baudelaire j'ai compris que travailler
et est plus amusant que de s'amuser moi
je travaille 15 heures par jour et ça ne
m'empêche pas de vivre par ailleurs mais
ces graines ce qui m'amuse le plus
j'aurais simplement de petites
conclusions et je vous laisse en paix je
parle décidément comme les curés
aujourd'hui mais d'abord je pense qu'il
ya un point très important mais
j'imagine que vous allez en parler
aujourd'hui mais qui ne me regarde pas
mais je pense que c'est très important
l'ubs risation du monde je reprends le
vocabulaire de maurice lévy l'ubs au
lieu de bombes pour interdire über pop
d'accord très bien je comprend enfin
c'est comme l'eau s'infiltre partout
l'économie collaborative où les vitres
et pare elle lui brise à sion du monde
elle sera dans tous les domaines et puis
on va pas interdire airbnb on va pas
interdire blabla car et c est donc il
vaut mieux réfléchir à deux choses il
vaut mieux les fiscaliser plutôt que les
interdire et dieu de il vaudrait mieux
avoir une réflexion sur le travail
indépendant
beaucoup beaucoup de salariés va passer
du côté du travail indépendant et notre
code du travail absolument pas adapté à
sa mieux vaut fiscalisés ces gens plutôt
que de les empêcher de travailler mais
je les fiscaliser modérément il s'agit
pas non plus de l'eau et puis on parlait
tout à l'heure de la génération y
alors bon d'abord il ya la z aujourd'hui
et
honnêtement ça s'arrange pas sur le plan
du travail
le phénomène majeur des 50 dernières
années c'est que nos enfants qui sont
par ailleurs adorable j'ai trois fils et
des merveilles évidemment comme les
vôtres mais il travaille beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup moins que dans les
jets d'eau si on préfet de précédentes
c'est incontestable sont largement aussi
intelligente nous problème ya pas une
mutation génétique mais il travaille
beaucoup moins je vais vous donner un
exemple tout mais professeur à la
sorbonne alquier canguilhem et les
autres avaient fait leurs tests
complémentaires en latin je vais vous
dire écrire en latin ou parler en latin
ne demande aucune intelligence la preuve
tous les romains y arrivait même les
imbéciles mais en revanche pour un petit
français faire une tête de 400 pages
comme jaurès en latin ça demandait une
quantité de travail
inimaginable la génération y pour des
raisons il faut réfléchir à ça des
raisons je peux pas analysé l'un ce
serait trop long mais elle travaille
beaucoup moins que les générations
précédentes et c'est un véritable
problème parce qu'elle a été aussi
saisis par cette idéologie des 35 heures
par cette idée que le travail c'était
l'ennemi
je vous donne juste un exemple et je
termine avec ça un exemple plaisant mais
significatif j'avais évidemment quand
j'étais ministre de la jeunesse puisque
j'étais aussi ministre de la jeunesse un
conseiller jeunesse qui était jeune on
m'avait dit il faut prendre un jeune en
effet si j'avais pris un type de 80 ans
pour faire conseiller jeunesse serait
très bizarre et puis un soir je le vois
tous pâlichon et parce que quand même il
faut bien dire qu'on travaille dans les
ministères contrairement à ce qu'on
croit parfois on travaille même beaucoup
donc j'avais fait passer la loi chaud
pourquoi sur les assistants d'éducation
et donc tout le monde était quand même
un peu fatigué parce qu'on rentrait à 2h
3h du matin et puis je vois mon
conseiller jeunesse a particulièrement
pâlichon je le prends par le coup je
l'emmène dans mon bureau je lui offre un
petit whisky pour essayer de remonter le
moral du marin et surtout le mien au
passage et et il me dit ça m'a fait
tellement rire parce que c'était à la
fois plaisanterie mais en même temps
c'était
assez profond il me dit ah ah monsieur
le ministre vous savez j'avais demandé
un emploi pas un travail
merci à vous c'est mignon un grand merci
à